hello today i will be talking about the
this work of feeding classical
impossibility of position verification
this is joint work with jiahui liu and
shipon leo
so let me begin by introducing the task
of position verification
so you can think of the task as being
having approver which
wishes to convince the verifier that he
is at a certain position
so
for this talk we'll think of the proverb
being an astronaut
and um the verifiers being
people on the earth
so
one thing we can do
is call distance bonding which
informally is the following so a
verifier being on the earth wants to
know where the approver is
but what he could do is to send a
message
and if the prover responds within a
certain time then he is certain that um
the prover must be within this region by
no faster than light communication
principle of special relativity
so in order to improve the position what
you could do is to just have
multiple verifiers and repeat this
process
and then you can at the end triangulate
where the prover is
but the issue with this approach
is that if
there are multiple provers or there are
multiple adversaries and they are
colluding
then they can actually incorrectly
convince the verifiers that they are at
an incorrect position so in this example
they can convince the verifier that they
are at this location while in reality
when it's over here when it's over there
and none of them are even close to this
position so in general um
let's focus
for simplicity's sake let's focus on one
dimensional and we are going to consider
something like a minkowski diagram so
the horizontal axis represents
the
location or x-axis
and the vertical axis axis represents
time so times goes on as you go up
and furthermore messages travel at speed
of light so in general let's say there
is approver and there are two verifiers
without loss of generality and approver
wants to come in the verifiers that he
is at this certain location
so without loss of generality we can
assume that the protocol looks something
like this
the verifier on the left is going to
send some message and
and the verifier on the right is also
going to send another message and the
timing is made so that um these two
messages
arrive at the prover in the middle at
the same time
so the prover in the middle upon
receiving these two messages is going to
compute some function
that is a function on both m0 and m1 and
then spit out the response to both
parties
and at the end these parties are going
to check whether they get uh
the correct response are and
unfortunately even for something as
general generic as this there is a gen
also a generic attack that um attacks
this position verification protocol
so think of the following scenario where
there are two adversaries
none of them are in the middle and their
goal is to
compute r
um on each side and while the timing
constraint uh is such that they only
have one run of simultaneous
communication unfortunately there is a
very natural attack to do which is that
the anniversary on the left upon
receiving m0 is going to
remember m0 for himself and at the same
time
send a copy of m0 to the adversary on
the right which corresponds to this
error
and similarly for the adversary on the
right you can also do something similar
which is keep m1 for himself and then
send a copy to the bursary on the left
and then after one hour of communication
they both know m zero and m one and
therefore can compute r and furthermore
uh so first let's observe that um this
attack is actually very efficient in
fact it's as efficient as what the
honest prover does and furthermore even
if f is designed to be a randomized
function instead of a deterministic
function
you can still derandomize this process
by having these two adversaries sharing
some randomness
and then this f is essentially
randomized to be a deterministic
function and the same attack goes
through
and furthermore because it's efficient
even if you
consider computational assumptions
um you still cannot get around this
impossibility
okay
so um the impossibility i mentioned
before
is given by this work by chandra at all
in 2009
um
in that work they also consider
constructing a protocol against um
abundant anniversary in particular
boundary storage adversaries
and
after that
basically all non-position verifications
that achieve
security against including adversaries
must they all use the power of quantum
in particular they use quantum
communications starting off with the
work of kent and
there are a long list of work that i
that this list is not meant to be
complete so in this talk
um what we construct is that um if we
assume that learning with errors
is hard against quantum computers we
construct uh position verifications
against
quantum adversaries
but the protocol is classically
verifiable
in particular
this means that the verifiers are
entirely classical
in particular they don't possess any
quantum computation powers and the
protocol
is classical communication so the
verifiers only need to send classical
messages and receive classical messages
so a natural question is whether we can
do better
unfortunately we also show that
for a classically verifiable protocol
you must have a quantum improver
in particular
this kind of protocol would also
imply the existence of what's known uh
what is known as proofs or quantumness
and therefore you you also have to
assume some computational assumptions um
you cannot construct
unconditionally secure
position verification that are
classically verifiable
so before i go into the construction
let me first motivate why it is a good
idea
to have classical communication
or classical verifiable position
verifications from a practical
perspective
so
the most important thing is that
for position verification the only
reasonable model of communication is
wireless communication or free space
communication
and a feature of free space
communication is that they inherently
has
they inherently have a high loss
and this is especially an issue when
you are sending quantum messages
due to the intricate nature of quantum
states
so starting with the work of gn syopsis
in 2015 they show that um non-quantum
division verification protocols actually
break down when the loss is high so in
particular this means that
either they lose on completeness which
means that um
the
honest proverb can convince the verifier
or soundness which means that um
including adversaries cannot be
the position verification protocol
okay so uh following that work there is
also um a few words that studies lost
tolerance quantum position verifications
where they reach the
essentially raises the threshold in
which uh for which the position
verification protocol
will still work furthermore there are
also these two works showing that um
during protocols where
they achieve full loss tolerance but the
security only is
that their protocols are only secure if
the adversaries are unentangled however
you can notice that all of these issues
will be non-existent if we only consider
classical communications
because
for classical communications we can
simply
repeat the message multiple times
and this will not
introduce any intricacies in the
security argument and therefore
the corollary of our work is that we
actually achieve
full loss tolerance
position verification protocols
even against adversaries that are
entangled although
i will not explain how to achieve and
security against entanglement in this
talk some further
motivations for getting classical
verifications include that if you think
about free space content communications
they usually use a tracking laser to
make sure that they're sending the
message to the correct
space or correct location
and this is something
that is not very efficient
and again for classical communication
you don't need um this kind of accuracy
and finally um if your protocol is
quantum
has content communication
then it might be harder to compose
your protocol with other things that you
might want uh for
position-based cryptography for example
you might want to authenticate the
message and this becomes a little bit
harder and
a little bit more subtle when you're
considering quantum communication
okay so let me talk about
how first let me talk about how to get
quantum position verifications with
quantum communications
as shown by previous work
so let's go back to this diagram
so the prover is in the middle
and
now he instead has some quantum device
here i'm considering something that is a
measurement device that measures a
photon
and
so this protocol that we'll be looking
at has the particular property which is
that there is only one message that is
quantum in particular the first message
sent by the
verifier on the left is going to be a
single photon
that encodes a bb-84 state
which essentially is
one of the four possible
states which we will denote as 0 1 or
plus or minus or h of 0 h of 1. so in
other words you can encode one of these
four possibilities by two bits uh one
bit b and b the other bit being theta uh
they are denoting the basis that the bit
is encoded in
and
so this is the first message and the
other message sent by the verifier on
the right is the basis theta to the
approval in the middle
so the prover in the middle upon
receiving the basis theta is going to
measure this
photon at the same time
in the this correct basis to recover b
that is encoded in the photon and then
he is going to report the measurement
results to both ends
and then both ends can check whether the
brewer has recovered the correct bit
okay
so if you look at um so i'm not going to
show why they secure but on a high level
this protocol gets around the
impossibility because if you recall the
impossibility explicitly asks you to
copy
this message
which is that this adversary is supposed
to remember this quantum state and also
send a copy which is something that you
cannot do
in general uh for quantum states
and here uh if you they i can actually
probably show that
uh because theta cannot reach the left
adversary in time without knowing see
that this state is actually provably
unclonable which
in turn established that this protocol
has
is secure even against
quantum adversaries so given this
protocol let's go back and reflect on
the position verification impossibility
basically
the way that they evade this
impossibility
is that um
it's by this bubble in particular i said
f can always be efficiently randomized
but um
but here instead of considering a
classical function f they are
considering something that is inherently
quantum and therefore this it is clear
that this impossibly
impossibility holds only if f is a
classical function and therefore
together on the impossibility um given
this example we know that f must the
function f must be inherently quantum
for example in the
last example f is taking quantum inputs
however there is also another idea of
getting a quantum function
especially if you want classical
communication then this f is just a
function
but um maybe you instead we need to have
a classical function that is inherently
content which means that only a quantum
computer can evaluate this function and
one idea is that maybe we can make
prover prepare some computationally
unclondable states
similar to a bb-84 state that is
unclonable unconditionally earlier we i
mentioned that um classical verifiable
physician verification implies proof of
continuous
and therefore a natural place to look
for these computationally unclonable
states would be to look at proof of
condomless protocols
and in particular we'll look at
um the protocol by practical
which uses the following um primitive
which is called trapdoor cloud 3
functions
so on a high level a
class v function is a function that is
parameterized by a public key that maps
end bits to m bits
and clock readiness means that this
function is two to one
and it is hard
but class 3 means that it is hard to
find a collision in this function
efficiently
for a random public key
and the trapdoor property says that when
you are sampling the public key you will
also sample a trapdoor along with the
public key which allows you to invert
this function for that particular public
key
in particular
for any output y
using this trapdoor you can efficiently
recover the two pre-images denoted by x0
and x1
and furthermore we will also be going to
use another property called
adaptive hardcore bit
which
i will not introduce for now
okay so with trapdoor clock free
function let's see how we construct a
proof of continuous
uh
which is the protocol given by uh this
work of breaker scale
so the task of proof of quantumness on a
high level is that
it is an interactive proof between a
classical verifier and a quantum
improver such that if the plural is
quantum then she can convince the
verifier that the proverb is quantum but
if the prover is classical and uh the
proverb is efficient
then no matter what the plural does she
cannot convince the verifier that
he is a quantum
party or algorithm
okay so using trapdoor club free
function
uh the protocol goes as following so
first the verifier is going to sample
a trapdoor free function and then he's
going to send the public key to the
approver
so the proverb being a quantum
cpu or a quantum party what he can do is
to prepare
an equal superposition of
all the possible preimages x
and then evaluate this uh fpk in
superposition
um and in the end what he will get is
this quantum state
and then he is going to measure
the the output register of fpk
which gives him a classical
output denoted here by y
and then he is going to send this y to
the verifier
so the post measurement state upon
measuring this y
uh you can show is exactly an equal
superposition of x0 and x1 where x0 and
x1 are pre images of y
and the verifier having the trapdoor can
as we mentioned efficiently in word y
and recover x0 and x1
so
the next thing the verifier is going to
do is to sample a random coin theta uh
denoting the basis that the prover
should be measuring
and
in particular if theta is zero the
plural is going to measure this state in
the standard basis otherwise if theta is
one then the prover is going to measure
this state in the hadamard basis and
then the
prover reports the measurement results
to the verifier
and then uh you can see that um for each
of the bases the mesh uh the verifier
can classically check whether this
measurement outcome is consistent with
this state
so the adaptive hardcore bit property
that i mentioned earlier can be
intuitively thought of as the property
that um
for any
even quantum adversary
he cannot produce
uh three triple y
and zero and s1
such that yn0 passes the first
verification while y ends one passes the
second verification
um simultaneously with probably much
higher than one-half
so we know how to construct uh
a noisy variant of the trapdoor
classroom function from
quantum hardness of lwe
but for this talk it will be simpler to
simply think of triple crochet functions
for now so intuitively you can see that
the adaptive hardcore big is it
immediately gives you the fact that this
protocol is a proof of continuous
this is because if a classical adversary
could pass this test with probably let's
say one then you can always rewind this
classical adversary and send him a
different theta in which case you will
be producing
this three tuple with y and zero z and
zero s1
both passing the verification which
violates the adaptive hard copy
however this is actually saying some
something much stronger
which is that this post measurement
state um
is actually unclonable by the adaptive
hardcopy property the argument is very
similar to before
in particular
if you assume you can clone
up to some
approximation
then you can
have two copies and measure one copy in
the standard basis and the other copy in
the hardware basis so if your cloning is
good
it's very good
then i should be able to produce both n0
and s1 with higher probability than one
half
which is a contradiction
okay so there seems to be some
computational unclonability here so
let's try to use this
tcf state for
classical population verification
so the first attempt here is that we are
going to take the bb-84
based quantum position verification
protocol and instead just instead of
sending a bb-84 state over here i'm just
going to sample a tcf public key and
send this public key to the
um
quantum approver
and then the quantum improver is going
to do exactly
the proof of quantumness protocol
in particular he is going to um
produce this
equal superposition and evaluate f
he is going to measure this y
and then measure this x
either in standard basis or hardware
basis
given by theta and then he is going to
report the measurement results to both
ends
actually this protocol already seems to
evade the classical impossibility
in particular if you recall this is the
classical impossibility
of course you can still do the same
thing as before as these messages are
classical so this adversary can copy
these messages and send them to each
other
however
the issue is that at the end
because this
measurement is
randomized
the verifiers will see a different
response with high probability
and therefore if we add the check that
the verifiers are going to check whether
they receive the same response then this
seems to already evade the classical
impossibility
okay but unfortunately there is actually
an attack for this protocol
and
the the high level idea of this attack
is that
this adversary does not need to prepare
the state honestly
in particular what
the version on the left could do is to
actually guess which theta it is and
then prepare two transcripts of the
execution
so in particular he is going to guess
theta is zero and then run
the product called once with sigma theta
being zero
and then guess theta being one and run
the product called
we set up being one and get another
transcript
and then after one round of
communication where the obviously on the
right simply forwards theta
they can simply pick out the transcript
that corresponds to the correct theta
and then report the correct y ends to
both parties
and this actually simulates the
the honest
prover perfectly
and therefore
unfortunately our first attempt is
actually insecure
however
you can see that this protocol is
insecure
due to a very simple reason which is
that
in the proof of quantumness protocol the
plural sees theta
after he has sent y
however here there is no such constraint
and therefore if we make the prover
commit to y then maybe the adversary
also
needs to commit to y before
picking theta which might make this
attack go away
so the second attempt is very similar to
the first attempt in particular
the verifier on the left is still going
to send public key to the approver
but the timing constraint is changed a
little bit so that um
the verifier on the right is actually
going to send the theta message actually
a little bit later than
this read message
and then
so the approver is going to receive the
red message first
and then he is going to prepare this
state and then report y as before
and then upon receiving theta is then
going to measure the host measurement
state in the correct basis
so
at the end at the end they are going to
check the measurement result
so the main thing here is that the
verifier is going to do another check
which is that they are going to ensure
that
the message y receives
is received before ends
in particular
this message should not depend it should
not be possible for this message to
depend on the trace of theta
so i it turns out that this protocol
actually can be proven secure
so i am not going to do the full proof
for this talk if you are interested you
can
look at our paper or one of the main
ingredient is what is called a
computational non-local games of
charitable car free functions
so this could be understood as the
following so again this is the proof of
quantumness protocol that is forerunned
by brexit at all
and in order to make it a computational
non-local game
what we're going to do is that instead
of doing the um last two runs
we're actually going to add um
before that we are going to add another
thing which is that we are going to ask
the prover
to split himself into two halves
so this is his condom state uh
presumably he has some internal state
after the first two messages
we are going to ask the plural to split
into two halves i and then
we are going to separate these two
halves physically
and then
the verifier is going to
finish
the protocol with these two halves in
particular he is going to sample one
theta as before
and then send this theta to both halves
and then both half is going to is
supposed to report
the measurement outcome to the verifier
in the middle to emphasize here that
uh the two halves are getting the same
theta instead of um two independent
theta uh of course these two halves can
be entangled uh which is why it is a
non-local game and what we've shown in
the paper is that the success
probability of any efficient prover
that is able to pass both checks is
bounded by three quarters plus
negligible
you can think of it as some kind of
computational unclonable property
because of course if you can clone this
state then
um
you can always simulate
a proof of quantumness proverb with
basically no loss and therefore
you you are able to successfully pass
these
checks with probably essentially one but
the fact that uh this is significantly
significantly less than one shows that
this day must be unclonable even if
the
adversary could do whatever he wants
including not following the protocol
to conclude
i will mention some other results
uh
so
the protocol that i've shown before
um actually only achieves sunless
three-quarters against efficient quantum
adversaries
and we showed
uh in the paper that you can get the
soundness down to negligible by
essentially parallel repetition
and the analysis is um borrowing some
ideas from existing works are listed
here
and also the security
um while i did not show the proof but it
only works for i entangled adversaries
in order to bootstrap the
basic uh booster of the protocol to make
it secure against entangled adversaries
we
uh we borrow some
existing ideas
uh from um quantum position verification
and what we are able to achieve is that
if we assume
quantum lwe is sub exponentially hard
then we get a protocol that is secure
against funded entanglement
and if you want security against
unbounded and entanglement we can also
get it um by combining some combining
our protocol with the protocol of unrule
which gives you security against
unbounded entanglement in the quantum
random oracle model
and finally for our protocol we also
show that it is actually
insecure so the base version is actually
insecure against entangled adversaries
and this attack can be carried out
efficiently
so finally
some future directions include that
extending our work to
high dimensional since we only consider
one-dimensional position verification
and then
there is also seems to be some
trade-offs between the attacks
in particular
if you spend exponential time you can
break any classical verification
protocol
on the other hand for our
standard model
construction if you have share some
entanglement you can also break the
protocol efficiently without spending
exponential time
so it is interesting whether there are
some trade-offs between using time and
entanglement
and a more interesting question is
for our construction
we used uh some notions of
uncomfortability
and uh
it seems like as a consequence the on
explorer has to have some quantum memory
throughout the protocol
and he has to keep the memory coherent
for some time
so it would be interesting if we
construct a
classical verifiable position fire
position verification without uh
on its program having any quantum memory
finally
it will also be interesting to weaken
the assumption or if we can get
an unbounded
entanglement security without
proving the security in an ideal model
so with that
i conclude my talk thank you very all
for listening